what's up i'm eric nam and i'm here
today to tell you about jesus okay sorry
hey guys what's up my name is eric nam
and today i'm here at buzzfeed to read
your thirst tweets part
two am i the first part two
wow okay
i'm excited to be here terrified
slightly nervous scared a lot of mixed
emotions to preface it we asked for your
thirst tweets which may or may not have
been a mistake
it may have been a mistake i haven't
seen these obviously the first time was
memorable oh man you guys are so
aggressive step on me i'm not gonna step
on you if you pay me enough i mean
anything's possible watch this with
caution if your mom or dad or
grandparent or relative is near you get
them away save this your algorithm for
later here we go
oh god i'll give you 300 cash for you to
step on me please and thank you
no i'm not gonna do it you are worth
more than 300 and my foot steppage is
worth more than three hundred dollars
also very painful i don't know why you
would want that since the last third
suites video by the way the signs at my
concerts have become a lot more graphic
people have signs that literally just
say step on me
how much is enough i don't know maybe in
part three we can answer how much is
enough i want eric to legally adopt me
just so i can call him daddy listen you
can call me whatever you want you can
call me daddy without me having to adopt
you also i heard adoption is really
expensive raising a child is also very
very expensive schooling clothing
feeding inflation i don't know if i can
afford to raise a child right now so i'm
gonna respectfully decline and i'm sure
your parents are great mike
my ideal weight is eric numb on top of
me
thank you i'll just say i think i'm a
lot heavier than i look so maybe hard to
breathe
just physics what is with this
excuse me excuse me daddy sorry daddy
sorry daddy sorry daddy sorry
daddy
sorry i keep seeing things on my socials
where it's just people just keep calling
me daddy i honestly don't know how to
feel am i supposed to feel flattered i
think i'm just confused just another
good day that would be better if eric
nama choked me
you guys a lot of issues going on it's
always been aggressive here stepage
choking daddy
is that a word it's not gonna happen i
want you to breathe i want you to live
i'll lick eric nam's toes dot dot for
research purposes
it's probably stinky probably smelly a
little clammy that's what i'm gonna tell
you to deter you from licking my toes i
don't know if i would like you to it's
just gonna be tickly it's gonna be wet i
i do not consent it's me it's not you
oh my gosh
i let aaron
carve his name into my ovaries but
that's a conversation for another time
xoxo this sounds like a conversation for
never time that's painful any part of an
internal organ having something carved
into it has to be painstakingly
horrendous also i don't like the sight
of blood again it's not a you thing it's
a me thing choke me slam me hit me with
your car and i'll thank you
i know what you're trying to do here
you're trying to get an insurance payout
i'm not here for it insurance rates are
high as they are and i'm not trying to
go to prison no how do you like your
eggs in the morning scrambled or
fertilized i like mine fertilized
i'm not ready for children you're going
to have to hold on to your eggs
sheesh someone mentions eric nah me
caution
slippery when wet
because you're taking a shower i get it
cause you're walking in the rain down
the subway stairs they are very slippery
when wet don't fall hit your head safety
first guys well then i need to say eric
i need you to braille me like we the
last two people left on earth and we
need to bring the earth population back
to seven billion wow i don't know if we
could create that many children also
it's got to be very taxing on everyone
seven buildings a lot have you washed
your face today yet i need to make sure
my seat is clean for like
you guys these are i should really read
through them before i read them out loud
i'm getting red like i feel my ears
physically getting red right now my face
is not a seat okay i do clean my face
twice a day with some incredible
k-beauty cleansers to keep it clean i
shouldn't have asked to do this i forgot
how hard this is i'm not into watching
sunsets but i'd love to see you go down
down down down down down down down i
have a song called down for you that's
what this tweet is about i really
appreciate that you love the song so
much that you you tweeted this to me
thank you
wow dear eric nam i have three holes but
most importantly a heart that could love
you to pieces while you rip me apart
thank you
i do you hear that that is what's going
through my head
you have a heart that could love me to
pieces just aggressively love me and i
appreciate that hey eric i'm going
horseback riding next week but i'm a
little scared since it's my first time
mine if i practice riding on
i personally think that there are a lot
of differences between human and horse i
don't think it would be good practice i
don't know save me here
eric what's the difference between me
and sunglasses sunglasses sit higher on
your face
wait
what
got it you really thought that one
through didn't you these people are so
creative how the hell do you come up
with me since i don't have a driver's
license you can do the driving and i can
do the writing i'm a really good driver
my uber lift rating is 4.9 stars as well
i'm like really proud of it yeah just
let me know i can pick you up drop you
off whatever you need be good
oh man
eric nam more like eric rabbit in my ass
oh my
lord sheesh you're gonna just
pass on this one i feel red i appreciate
the passion i appreciate the love i
don't so much appreciate the
objectification of my face but thank you
i don't think we'll be doing this again
i was like hey buzzfeed can we do some
stuff i have a new album out called
they're back again and i'm on tour
everything's on ericdom.com i forgot how
uncomfortable this was thank you
bye
[Music]
you